welcome back to las vegas now if you are
ready to become a part of a financial
institution that has great rates cool
benefits and personalized service it's
time to join silver state schools credit
union the sponsors of this next segment
mercedes talked to president and ceo
scott r kills about how they're helping
our members or their members and the
community check it out
so great to have you back on scott we've
got some exciting things to talk about
i'm super excited because we have the
whitney grand reopening to talk about
that's right mercedes in fact i was just
out of the whitney branch to uh look at
it this last week and uh silver state
school credit union is celebrating our
grand reopening of the remodeled whitney
brand um and that will be tomorrow
friday uh june 10th so this beautiful
new space allows our members really to
enjoy an improved full service
experience but we invite invite
everybody to stop by from 2 30 to 4 30
uh for some refreshments uh we'll have
the csn cheerleaders we'll have cash the
soccer rocker the life football club
llama which as you know is a crowd
favorite um and uh and there'll be an
official ribbon cutting and the best
thing is is that you mercedes will also
be there to help us celebrate uh thanks
to mix 94.1 fm and you
um so our whitney branch is located at
683 north stephanie street in the target
shopping center and that's on the north
west corner of north stephanie at sunset
road
and so it's right across from the
galleria marlon henderson we hope to see
all of you there too and while you're
there something that i've been wanting
to talk to the people at silver state
schools credit union about because i am
a member and i've been thinking about
refinancing my auto loan and ccsu has an
auto loan refinance program that will
help your members
save money and then they actually get to
take what's called a payment vacation
and i like the sound of this what is a
payment vacation yeah sure so two times
a year we do this thing called a better
car or the avc loan promotion um and as
you know and you mentioned well summers
are are known for family vacations and
so what we do is we offered uh this loan
program at this time of year and also at
christmas uh and and you can
additionally benefit from that 90 day
payment vacation so that that's 90 days
the first payment um and i think
everybody knows that you know we read it
in the news all day uh gas prices are up
we have additional expenses these days
um some people are having to skip
vacations because they can't afford them
so this is a great way to take that
summer vacation from your auto loan
payment and actually use it towards your
your uh
vacation so additionally the abc loan
gives you an opportunity to save up to
two percent off your current auto loan
rate when you refinance your current
auto loan with silver state school
credit union in essence really what it
does is it allows you to lower your
interest rate reduce your monthly auto
loan payment maybe catch up on some of
those bills that we were talking about
or add to your savings account and all
those goals of course are subject to
approval uh but uh to learn more about
the abc
loan program we want you to visit
silverstatecu.com
abc for details
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring that segment if you
have any questions about their special
on abc loans call 702-733-8820
or visit silverstatecu.com
abc loans we'll be right back